Jessica Clemens here with some
apocalypse talk new rockstars has
partnered with universal home
entertainment to create this video and
give you a special behind the scenes
look at knock at the cabin sometimes
something as small as their outfits or
designs can have bigger meaning which
Carolyn Duncan gets into with the white
bags over their faces for the sacrifice
story-wise the hood has to feel like
something that one of them or all of
them
made themselves we found Fabrics that
you can see everyone's features through
them which is incredibly important
tonight and what makes it more
triggering is you still see their
outline features with the mask on it's
not even a sacrifice anymore it's a
public execution at first you don't know
who to trust or believe as the audience
so you don't know if these people are
murderers with an agenda but it makes it
more personal and More Human After
introducing themselves when you see
their features as they say their final
words before dying in the hoods it's
completely dark but it's that eeriness
that creepiness that draws us in